Mesdames et Messieurs chers famille qui
êtes là Monsieur le Maire de
Sainte-Geneviève-des-Bois
c'est avec une profonde tristesse que
nous avons appris
c'était le 2 février dernier
la disparition de notre collègue Olivier
Léonard
sénateur de l'Essonne et on est tout
juste d'avoir 58 ans
il nous a quitté à l'issue d'un combat
long de plusieurs années d'un combat
acharné contre la maladie
il l'a mené avec courage et
détermination
j'étais présent
la très très belle cérémonie d'hommage
organisée le 10 février à
Sainte-Geneviève-des-Bois à laquelle on
va assister de nombreuses personnalités
politiques et j'allais dire beaucoup
d'habitants
beaucoup d'habitants de Sainte-Geneviève
au cours d'une intervention
particulièrement émouvante la présidente
Laurence Rossignol il y a relaté de
manière très personnelle mais aussi
pudique 35 années d'amitié indéfectible
avec Olivier Léonard
le président Jean-Claude Roquier
a aussi évoqué très justement les
valeurs humanistes
laïque et républicaine
qu'Olivier Léonard avait en partage avec
le groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
social européen
la passion de l'engagement politique
a 116 guider la vie d'Olivier Léonard
c'était pour lui une manière de servir
un idéal au bénéfice de l'intérêt
général de ces concitoyens
il était né le 29 janvier
1964 à Suresnes dans une famille juive
laïque
ses grands-parents nous l'avons évoqué
avec la famille avait été victime du
nazisme
ce drame familial est sans doute à la
racine très profonde du combat permanent
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme qui
a été le sien et qu'il est bon de
rappeler
à cet instant
à l'âge de 20 ans il fut en 1984 l'un
des co-fondateurs de SOS Francis côté de
Malek Bouti d'Arlen désir et de Julien
Doré
Olivier Léonard c'était également engagé
dans la vie militante en participant en
Mouvement des Jeunes Socialistes et ce
dès le début des années 80 à la veille
de l'élection de François Mitterrand
lorsqu'il était encore lycéen au lycée
Turgot puis comme étudiant à la faculté
de Tolbiac des amitiés qui se sont
poursuivis bien au-delà de la Faculté
son engagement militant au sein de la
gauche socialiste se poursuivit par la
découverte du Parlement
lorsqu'en 1991 il suivit l'Assemblée
nationale comme attaché parlementaire
Julien Dray devenu député de l'Essonne
élu conseiller municipal de
Sainte-Geneviève-des-Bois en 1995
Olivier Léonard en devint ma mère
adjoint puis maire en 2001 il s'investit
à fond dans ce qu'il considérait être le
plus beau des mandats et furet lui mère
a deux reprises en 2008 et 2014
preuve d'un réel attachement des
génothéva à son égard
il ne renoncera pas
mais 20 2017 après son élection au Sénat
il dû se mettre en conformité avec la
législation sur le cumul des mandats
comme l'avait souligné en février notre
collègue Laurence Rossignol il s'était
je cite révélé et épanoui dans la
fonction de maire ce pourquoi il était
fait
à l'occasion de son départ de la mairie
il exprimait avec beaucoup de justesse
ce qui incarnent cette fonction une
passion pour l'intérêt général l'amour
de sa ville et aussi le dévouement total
pour nos concitoyens dans tous les
moments qui ponctuent leur quotidien
beaucoup d'entre nous qui ont connu
cette vie de maire comprennent dans les
mots d'Olivier Léonard ce que ça veut
dire réellement
de mandat
transformation
la façonna en quelque sorte à son image
fait d'humanisme de fraternité
défenseur acharné de son territoire au
sein de la grande couronne de l'île de
France Olivier Léonard avait aussi
compris que l'intercommunalité pouvait
apporter une dimension supplémentaire à
l'action publique mais il a bataillé
pour empêcher la constitution d'une
intercommunalité géante c'était la mode
à l'époque de 800 000 habitants et il a
présidé à partir de 2008 une structure
intercommunale la taille plus humaine
d'ailleurs le nom ou l'évoquera la
Communauté d'agglomération du Val d'Orge
devenue en 2016 cœur des sommes
agglomération il y aura pour le
développement d'activités économiques et
culturelles et d'emploi de proximité
toujours et partout il appliquait le
principe de Jean Jaurès partir du réel
pour aller vers l'idéal
septembre 2017
Olivier Léonard si
son entrée au Sénat
il voyait dans le monde à parlementaire
une occasion de prolonger ses combats
locaux notamment celui
en faveur des départements de la grande
couronne l'élu des Yvelines que je suis
n'est pas totalement
indifférent à ce sujet comme avec les
autres collègues de l'Essonne qui
étaient autour de moi ce jour-là
il voulait conforter la place et
améliorer les conditions des habitants
de la grande couronne
Olivier Léonard advera au groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen et devant membres de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
qu'il a fait bénéficier de sa bonne
connaissance des dossiers notamment sur
un sujet majeur pour lui les transports
il sait notamment investi dans les
travaux sur le projet de loi
d'orientation des mobilités le
développement des mobilités étaient en
effet l'un de ses chevaux de bataille
avec une attention particulière portée
aux problématiques de desserts de
proximité et de désenclavagement
géographique moyen de réduire les
inégalités territoriales
en 2020 il rejoignait la commission des
affaires sociales
j'ai souvenir précis dans l'entretien
avec lui au sujet de l'égalité d'accès à
la santé qui était pour lui essentiel
mais aussi sa gratitude pour un système
de soins qui l'accompagnait dans la
solidarité et dans la qualité
son état de santé ne lui permettait pas
toujours de participer malheureusement
autant qu'il aurait souhaité aux travaux
du Sénat mais il tenait à venir siéger
parmi nous dès qu'il le pouvait
son combat
faveur des Kurdes a fait vibrer notre
hémicycle 27 mars 2018 regardez le
Journal officiel de nos débats ce
jour-là
il déclarait à l'occasion d'une question
d'actualité
protéger les Kurdes c'est défendre nos
valeurs c'est lutter contre le
terrorisme par conséquent c'est aussi
nous
sujets encore d'actualité
dans la continuité de son action locale
il était aussi resté encore et toujours
un inlassable défenseur de la laïcité
lors d'un débat c'est le 8 janvier 2020
Olivier Léonard s'exprime en ces termes
la laïcité ce n'est pas un règlement ce
n'est pas une loi ce n'est pas un point
d'équilibre d'une manière sympathique de
vivre ensemble c'est la protection de
tous les individus face à la tentation
d'une norme philosophique ou religieuse
promulguée hors de la démocratie fin de
citation
représentant du Sénat au sein de
l'Observatoire de la laïcité à partir de
février 2019
il s'appliqua fortement là encore comme
toujours dans la défense des valeurs
républicaines
Olivier Léonard a toujours eu pour ses
exceptionnel dévouement
je fais bien sûr référence à la tension
permanente qu'il portait à chacun mais
je veux aussi souligner sa pudeur
personnelle
son élégance morale celui qui a toujours
préféré une certaine discrétion à
l'ostentation
il était une référence d'engagement et
d'altruisme savait aussi
rassembler fédérer autour de lui des
personnalités
au service des actions qui
l'entreprenait et des valeurs qu'il
défendaient des valeurs pour lesquelles
parfois ils savaient aussi cliver pour
les affirmer avec force oui mes chers
collègues
souhaite que nous gardions d'Olivier
Léonard le souvenir d'un sénateur à la
fois chaleureux
à Sainte-Geneviève-des-Bois
l'image d'un humaniste le droiture doté
d'une culture étendue et d'une grande
curiosité intellectuelle
ces anciens collègues de la Commission
de l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable
ses collègues de la commission des
affaires sociales à ses amis du groupe
RDC je voudrais en dire tout le
sentiment que nous éprouvons
ses parents
Nelly et Gilbert
qui sont en face de moi
à son épouse Nathalie
et Ariane Frédéric son frère
sa famille ses proches ses amis ainsi
qu'à toute seule et tous ceux qui l'ont
accompagné tout au long de sa vie qui
ont partagé ses engagements je souhaite
dire comme je le redis
Homère et aux élus de
Sainte-Geneviève-des-Bois en ce moment
de recueillement la part que le Sénat a
pris réellement à leur deuil
votre peine a été et aujourd'hui encore
la nôtre nous avions noué ces liens
particuliers et rester parmi nous trop
de temps et pourtant chantons bien dans
tous les cas pour ceux qui l'ont
rencontré qui ont partagé qui parfois se
sont affrontés avec lui ils ne sont pas
indifférents au message d'Olivier
Léonard il restera ça n'est pas qu'un
mot pourtant des Loges présents dans nos
mémoires et je dois dire que regardons
le fauteuil qui était le sien à la fois
les valeurs qu'ils portent
le Tricolore qui est aussi présent les
valeurs qui dira dit quelque part il est
encore parmi nous